in the spirit of melvin ingram holding
in not holding out but holding in the
best current pass rush duos in the nfl
chris asked me the trivia oh that's
right all right here we go hold on a
second i gotta get to my text message
here all right here way to be prepared
you know it we know the purple people
eaters we know the steel curtain the new
york sack exchange
all right what defensive group was known
as the dome patrol
the dome patrol yeah that's made up uh
the oilers i don't know
nope nope you're wrong guess the wrong
dome team i mean what they didn't have
anybody to be trolling anybody on
defense the saints the saints the dome
patrol damn it
you didn't know that remember that ricky
jackson and sam mills and pat smiling
i remember them i don't remember the
dome patrol apparently it wasn't a good
enough nickname because it didn't catch
on you know what in all honesty i got a
couple of nicknames for you i don't
remember the nickname either and i'm a
football historian so i don't know where
matt casey came up with that crap i
don't know i'm not sure i got i got
nicknames i got nick's nicknames for you
that are not football historians oh
thank you okay very nice of you okay
here we go
i'm going i'm going to pittsburgh i'm
going to tj watt and bud dupreevil as
the best pass rushing duo in football
yeah i am to me you know they're they're
phenomenal outside linebacker defense
and they can drop into pass coverage and
do all that but you know the name of the
game in the name of the draft is pass
russian duo and i don't know i didn't
add up the numbers but i don't think
there was a combination that had more
higher sac numbers last year than those
two
maybe there is one other one you'll have
to figure that out but either way
they're very impressive they're the type
of guys where
you have to think about doubling them in
certain situations they're mismatches so
i'm going with bud dupree and tj watt
see now this is an issue we did not
address before this
does it have to be outside rushers or
can it be
any two members of your front four any
two all right
i did outside pass rushers i did outside
pass rushers that's that's because that
was within the spirit of what we were
talking about since it was melvin ingram
but okay go ahead bend the rules there
no i'm not bending the rules matt casey
just said it can be any two uh some
would say tj watt and cam hayward
because actually my research showed
before the show began
that tj watt and cam hayward actually
have more combined sacks over the last
three years than melvin ingram and joey
bosa so maybe you got the right team
maybe you got the right one but maybe
you didn't get the right other one maybe
hayward should i don't care about three
years ago don't talk about my picks like
that as dupree and what go ahead pick
your own damn i'm gonna fracture the
rules right out of the gate of course
you are i am gonna go i'm gonna go with
kansas city chris jones new contract
frank clark big contract last year i
don't care that chris jones is lined up
inside you can line up chris jones
anywhere the guy's disruptive he creates
havoc i want those two guys if i'm
starting my defensive line i got one on
the inside i got one on the outside and
they're gonna get after the quarterback
frank clark chris jones okay well it's
that's uh i i you know i can't argue
that they're not on there because i
didn't have the defensive tackles in
there but that's okay i like that that's
cool and chris jones is a stud so i'm
all good here with giving these guys
anything you want but all right after
this
whoo it's a tough one here to go which
one i want to go with here
i i'm going to go in the chargers i'm
going bosa and ingram i i truly believe
i think that's the second best combo out
there i do i i look at those two first
off i mean joey boso as we talked about
when he signed his contract yeah maybe
he's not the best defensive player in
football you know but he is
as we flushed out one of the four five
six best certainly in that combo melvin
ingram's been a force for a long long
time the press that defense is
predicated on their talents the success
of that defense is predicated on their
talents and they can do it all rush the
passer play the run do it all so i'm
going the bro graham
bosa and ingram
i am amazed amazed that you neglected
your team your buddies team i know san
francisco this is who i was you got the
right last name you got the wrong first
name give me nick boson d4 d ford's got
that knee cleaned up he said yesterday
not an issue at all this year fully
unleash d ford with uh the benefit of
having nick bosa attracting so much
attention on the other side great book
ends better than bosa and ingram ford
and nick bosa not joey bosa nick bosa
and d ford yeah
only reason i didn't pick it and you
know it's good to hear that d ford is in
the best in shapness of his life that's
very important
but uh well it is good to know that his
knees not messed up
come on let's be real no no you're right
it is i mean it's the only reason that's
what i was literally contemplating those
two and the reason i didn't pick them
was just because i feel like ford has
not been healthy and i didn't know where
to go here holy cow there's some good
ones here i can't even believe i'm gonna
leave some of these people
off the uh
i'm going chicago i'm gonna go there and
i'm leaving some good ones on the board
but i think khalil mack and robert quinn
uh that that's one that deserves to be
drafted no doubt about it i mean colin
mack to me i don't give a damn what
everybody looks at his stats last year
he's still one of the best outside
presents in the game you know so i look
at him and then robert quinn
he was the best pass rusher on the
cowboys last year not demarcus lawrence
it was robert quinn he was disruptive as
hell they paid him as so too so i'm
going to chicago and uh i'm going to go
with michael mack and robert quinn
you know some days reasonable minds can
differ on whether or not i won the draft
or you won the draft but but today
man i have just dunked on you like never
before oh my god i'm like you you guys
slide off the draft we're doing a pass
rush doing oh you dropped it jones you
jerk wait wait wait is is the draft best
defensive ends best edge rushing duo no
it was best pass rush duo that's the
draft that's what i did now for the last
two i will go pass rush edge duos von
miller how can how in the world i know
can you overlook the super bowl 50 mvp
who is in the midst of an intended
career rebirth with a healthy bradley
chubb on the other side of the line we
saw what they could do two years ago i
know now they're getting accustomed to
the vic fangio defense and chubb is
healthy give me chub and miller boom
bang pow dunked on you even though
you're six inches taller than me yeah
you didn't dunk on anything i like my
pass rush duo's better than yours i like
guys that actually have played a lot the
last few years and you like d ford and
chubb who don't play that much the last
few years so eat crap all right you're
wrong you didn't win this draft all
right
uh but
there's some good ones out here and
that's that was killing me the von
miller chub one because i mean in a lot
of ways the potential there is through
the roofs i mean we know that but we
didn't even prick i mean pick preston
smith and zadaria smith you prick okay
you got that i know
it slipped out from yesterday london
hello london yes uh we didn't even pick
them i mean that's unbelievable how
about shaquille barrett and jpp and yes
the guy led the nfl i know last year she
killed barrett did it just tells you
there's a lot of good ones out there and
some i'm some coming up the ranks too
you talk about the jags and what they
got there with josh allen clayvon chase
on and yannick and gawkway the skins
all right i keep saying that washington
i got to stop saying that i'm sorry
everybody out there montez sweat and
chase young i mean i thought about
putting them down
sweat didn't have a great year last year
put chase young out there they could
explode right right i mean they could be
the the new 49ers here this year you
know
it made me think last night actually
this about our redskins yesterday and
going man the redskins could play
through the defense and do all that did
it again you know did it two
times washington
do it again more
i grew up in the nfc east my dad was
phil sims it's going to take some time
to get that out
okay damn
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports